WESTBROOK IS ONE REBOUND AWAY.
THEY LEAVE CAPELA OPEN.
GALLINARI THE FADEAWAY.
THERE IT IS, HISTORY!
RUSSELL WESTBROOK HAS JUST
SURPASSED OSCAR ROBERTSON!
IT LASTED 47 YEARS AND NOW
RUSSELL WESTBROOK STANDS THERE
ALL ALONE!
>> Drew: A RECORD THAT WAS
TITLED UNTOUCHABLE FOR 47 YEARS
HAS BEEN BROKEN.
CONGRATULATIONS, RUSSELL
WESTBROOK.
>> Justin: RUSSELL WESTBROOK
DID SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE.
HE'S BEEN DESCRIBED AS NOT
HUMAN.
WELL, HE'S NOW THE ALL-TIME
TRIPLE DOUBLE LEADER WITH 182
AND THE WIZARDS HAVE CUT IT TO
FOUR.
>> Drew: JUST AMAZING.
>> Justin: A 15-0 RUN.
>> Drew: JUST UNREAL.
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN ABLE TO
WITNESS THE HISTORY IN THE
MAKING, AND NOW THAT RECORD
BEING BROKEN.
>> Justin: THEY JUST ANNOUNCED
IT IN THE ARENA,  AT STATE FARM
ARENA.
THE WIZARDS PLAYERS APPLIED.
THE FANS APPLAUD, AND THERE IS
RUSSELL WESTBROOK LOOKING UP.
HE DID IT.
>> Drew: IT'S NOTHING TO HIM.
HE KNOWS THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE
TIME